the supreme court not taking kamala's
attacks lying down after the vp dissed
the high court and said the decision to
overturn roe has made her worried about
their integrity
i think this is an activist court we had
an established
right
for almost half a century
which is the right of women to make
decisions about their own body
as an extension of what we have decided
to be the privacy rights to which all
people are entitled
and this court took that constitutional
right away
hmm
chief justice john roberts bashing
comments criticism and defending the
supreme court's legitimacy
the the court has always decided
controversial cases and that's the role
of the supreme court and that role
doesn't change simply because people
disagree with this opinion or that
opinion simply because people disagree
with an opinion is not a basis for
questioning the legitimacy of the court
all right so this is obviously i guess
it's referring to abortion so i'm going
to go to the guy first
[Laughter]
no what kind of politician jesse would
attack an institution like the supreme
court this is a threat to democracy is
she aware that she's putting their lives
in danger you know after someone tried
to kill kavanaugh she better watch her
words
i'm not usually a word policeman but
they just had a death threat against
canon the judge in the special master
case you know just just
back off a little bit i think i think a
equals b you say bad things then people
die it's on her i would never say that
but
i might
i don't think this is an activist court
if you listen to what ruth bader
ginsburg said the court that decided roe
was an activist court this court is
basically just kind of course correcting
here it's strange that
the liberals are so angry because those
supreme court justices the three that
trump appointed those were supposed to
be crookeds that's one of the main
reasons why they have so much rage
inside them he was never supposed to get
those appointments and notice the
democrats anytime they disagree with
anything they attack it is illegitimate
that trump is an illegitimate president
if you disagree with anything you're a
illegitimate scientist an illegitimate
businessman illegitimate doctor uh the
court is now illegitimate you can't do
that uh the democrats are all about
defending institutions then the next day
on meet the press you can't just slander
them that's true judge i mean we
you know we took a lot of heat for
criticizing the fbi and yeah she can
call she could just go right after the
supreme court which is basically the
super concentrated version of the fbi
with 90 percent more fbi-ness
well
well aside from all that i won't even
address it but the supreme court where
members of the supreme court there were
protests in front of their houses for
weeks on end an attempted assassination
of a supreme court justice all of that
spun off of this ginning up of this hate
and anger this is what the left is
trying to do they're trying to break
down the institutions as illegitimate
all of this all of the cornerstones of
america whether it's law and order
whether it's the courts whether it's the
constitution all that's illegitimate if
they don't like it and we're going to
protest even though there's coven
because we have a right to protest but
you don't it's really the them versus us
and that's what they're doing it's all
this is like all written out it's like
there's a playbook you know president
comes out there's the others they're not
the people that were on the side of and
if they get a decision they don't like
then as far as they're concerned the
court's an activist court the court is
far from an activist court it's not an
activist court the court is as jesse
said the writing and wrong that ruth
bader ginsburg herself a true feminist
said was not there was there was no
anchor in the constitution for this
right but you know the the most
interesting part of all of this is
whether or not the leak is something
that they're going to
going to investigate and going to uh
decide yes jessica speaking of the leak
i find it interesting it's such an
historic leak and yet the media has no
intention of really looking at it which
makes me think a liberal did it
was it you
you could confess here
yes right no one is watching
um
i i think people are pretty interested
in it there was a game of misdirection
that was going on when the leak happened
because republicans
didn't want to talk about the meaning of
the decision they didn't want to talk
about the implications because i think
mitch mcconnell and
smart republicans knew that this wasn't
going to end well for them i happen to
think that it was a conservative that
did it to hold kavanaugh and everyone
but essentially justice roberts in line
to keep those numbers there to the point
about it being an activist court i think
that justice roberts to some degree
actually thinks that it is because he
didn't side with everyone else he
thought they were going too far
he only agreed with part of the opinion
and i read this great washington post
article that basically said can we just
admit that judicial activism means
decisions i don't like and that everyone
just throws it around when they get a
bad one but this happens to be a really
bad one because it did undo a
constitutional rate that we've had for
over five decades and i know that ruth
bader ginsburg
didn't like the decision it was a 7-2
decision
with conservatives on there and it was a
privacy decision so yes there should
have been a codification of roe on a
national level um but this isn't just a
liberal problem dana is it really a
constitutional right just between you
and me
it's a bunch of bs yes yes and
that thing is also that the supreme
court said
congress you can pass a law right but
instead of kam lahara saying here's what
we're going to do i'm going to lead the
effort we're going to pass a law that we
can make fun of you make fun of if you
want but lindsey graham at least
introduced the law and you could pass
that and see what happens and then and
also you could let the states do it but
they're not doing any of that they're
just blaming the courts imagine if they
showed imagine if you're chuck todd on
meet the press and you're asking a
question about this and then you say let
me just show you a clip and you showed a
video of schoolhouse rock yeah how a
bill becomes a lot it says actually
congress can pass a law and then the
court checks it off they don't ever want
to do that think about the eviction
moratorium they knew that that was
illegal and they tried to do it anyway
they're doing the same thing on student
loans it's going to happen again and
one thing that she that i think that all
of us will find is that
inflation will be the top issue abortion
will be an issue and one of the ways
it's an issue is that it surged a ton of
money especially small dollars into
democratic campaigns and yet still as i
mentioned in the a-block republicans are
still holding strong they have to deal
with the issue they can't pretend that
abortion is not going to be an issue in
the campaign but an activist court is
not the problem the fact that they want
to
try to pass a law and then you won't
have to deal with all of this yes i
stopped listening after you said imagine
you're chuck todd yeah imagine i was
chuck todd you would said imagine your
chuck todd and i started to get very
nauseous and sad no no no they knew that
that'd be that'd be great then you could
think of all the questions you could ask
people who would be willing to come on
youtube ask the questions
think about all that rogaine i gotta get
up next liberal workers at the new york
times kicking and screaming over a
possible return to the office hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now